make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and
yeah let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and this title is not clickbait i
promise it is not clickbait it actually
happens it is
nightmare facing off against the living
tribunal and eternity and galactus and
the celestials and the whole nine yards
now you're probably asking yourself how
in the world
did nightmare become powerful enough to
even stand a chance against these guys
well i'll tell you exactly how
he beefed up his abilities using
skillshare so skillshare is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for creators and
curious people
you can explore new skills develop
existing ideas and get lost
in creativity one of my absolute
favorite courses is productivity for
creatives by thomas frank
and we actually follow each other on
twitter which is awesome but thomas
frank
is a youtuber who has a course on
skillshare this includes things like
time management being able to categorize
your different projects and make it all
make sense
you can get things done in a timely
fashion lord knows comics explain needed
it for a long
long long time so the first 1000 people
to use the link in my description will
get a free trial of skillshare premium
membership and after that
it's only around 10 a month but whether
you're looking to fend off boredom focus
on self-care through creativity or join
a similarly creative community
skillshare is the place to keep you
learning so make sure you guys check out
my link in the description and make sure
you guys get your free trial
to skillshare so having said all of that
we will find out exactly how nightmare
was able to do that in due time but
here's the thing about this
this comic and this is one of these
themes where i'm going to reach out to
you guys and ask you guys whether or not
you want to see it i won't do all of
them but i'll do some of them because
some of them are just really really bad
so this is what we call a showcase comic
for those of you guys who are unfamiliar
with this and you may have heard us
mention that in the past we talked about
things like
dc showcase and stuff like that this is
more or less a similar thing albeit from
marvel comics and the reason
why is because this features stories
that belong to other characters and i'll
tell you where these stories kind of
interject you know as we as we get
through this
but the way this kind of kicks off is
you have nightmare just sort of
appearing here now the portion that
we're covering which is called
overture this is drawn by alex ross for
those of you guys who are curious about
the artist and alex ross is like
the comic book artist right he's one of
my favorite probably my single favorite
comic book artists of all time
outside of like esau ribbik or or jim
chong right he's just he's ridiculously
good
but you basically have nightmare kind of
riding through here through this this
realm that we can only really presume to
be the dream dimension and it's just
kind of like you know this is a place
where i effectively control dreams right
or at least i
am able to manipulate and use the power
of dreams and we actually get this
really cool depiction of what is realm
looks like and this is one of the things
that you don't really see all
too often in marvel comics you do from
time to time but it's basically just
tons and tons of faces of people who
were just sleeping right now those of
you guys who aren't really familiar with
with nightmare
uh one i already have a video about
nightmare explained and then two
i can give you kind of a brief rundown
here and then you can reference the
video if you want to see more
so nightmare is what we call one of the
dreamlords and
in reality he's probably the most
powerful of the dreamlords but the basis
behind nightmare
is he basically garners his power or
feeds off the energy of people
as they dream right whether they're
having nightmares or they're having
peaceful dreams
he's empowered by them nonetheless now
as you would expect if like the entire
world fell into a slumber the nightmare
would remain powerful or probably even
be even more powerful right because the
reality is his power is limited and the
reason why
is because we as human beings do not
sleep 24 hours a day seven days a week
we only sleep for about
seven to eight hours a day or if you're
a college kid more like two so
because of that you know his power is
limited in so far
is how much dream energy he's able to
attain from people but what's going on
here is things have changed
things are different and the result is
that his power is currently being
amplified and so what he's kind of doing
here is he says he basically says like
when your world sleeps the dream energy
is mine for the taking and yet like
those in your world
i have imagined having more so i decided
to do something about it and now i have
the best of
all possible worlds and so what we end
up finding out here is that nightmare
has instigated what he considers to be a
hostile takeover
that here in the world everybody sleeps
all the time right they're just
constantly sleeping now here's the
important thing about this this story
didn't simply come out of nowhere right
it wasn't something that like kurt
busick and alex ross just thought of all
of a sudden this is a story that
actually kind of had its beginnings back
in captain america volume 3 in the late
1990s and the idea behind that story is
that that nightmare tried to do
exactly this he tried to instigate a set
of circumstances where
everybody in the world all the normal
humans all the super powered beings the
whole nine yards where they would just
be sleeping
all the time and that would be it now it
wasn't successful in this instance it
appears that it is
and so the result of that is that it
basically feeds him it strengthens him
and he even says that he says do you
understand
every fragment of every subconscious is
mind to control
every dream of love or fear or comfort
or escape
feeds me strengthens me it makes me
hungry for more
come let us have a taste of this one now
this is where the showcase element
begins to come into play and this is why
things are a little wonky so what this
is designed to do
is basically give us as the reader a
depiction of different writers and
different artists from marvel comics
in terms of what their skill set is now
not to discredit those writers and those
artists
we're not really going to cover these
just because of the fact that some of
these are
super in-depth and because of that like
each one of these could be its own video
and so literally this story arc would
end up being something like
you know like four hours long right
which i'm not really interested in doing
unless we end up doing like a full story
video where we combine a whole bunch of
smaller stories into one big story but
that's really what's kind of happening
here
is that nightmare is essentially taking
somebody on
a kind of tour of these various dreams
that individuals are having
while they're in their dream state now
the important thing to also understand
there's not really anything of
significance that comes
out of these stories involving these
dreams right so it's not as though
it kind of leads into the ending of all
this at least not that i'm aware of and
if there is we'll kind of go back and
we'll cover it
once we get to the actual conclusion of
the main story because this is only
really the first part we're only about
four or five issues out and we have one
issue left uh which i thought would be
kind of fun to cover
the thing about this is that the person
nightmare is basically talking to
is steven strange that steven strange is
the lone survivor out there right and
seemingly somewhere along the line when
all this began to happen
steven strange went into his corporeal
state right believing that either
nightmare or some other force was behind
it now one of the crazy things this is
kind of important here
we don't really get a lot of indication
about what happened beforehand
right all we really know is that it was
essentially stephen strange that made it
possible and this comes by way of
nightmare he says ironically i was able
to conquer the living realm because of
you as sorcerer supreme you have a
mystic connection to all living things
and now steven strange
every dream every dreamer in this world
belongs to me
including you and that's a cool thing
here it's kind of ironic to see that
doctor strange is his real
first enemy that he ever faced off
against and probably one of the most
powerful enemies that he has
is a guy that basically used him for his
own ends to essentially
take over the entirety of the waking
world to put it into sleep and to call
it a day now a lot of you guys might be
kind of asking yourself the question
like how could this possibly work so one
thing to understand about nightmare is
that in terms of his power set
he is the most powerful in his own realm
but he manipulates energy and magic just
like almost anybody else
uh it's not necessarily in the same
capacity as dormammu
and even in the realm of magic you do
have a hierarchy there the hierarchy is
usually a loose hierarchy because of the
fact that people's abilities and their
achievements
change so frequently because they're
invoking magic but say for example
somebody like doramu versus somebody
like sidorak we can make the legitimate
argument there
that sidorak is far and away more
powerful than dormammu why because
dormammu references the spells of
sidorak but it's not a one-to-one ratio
right just because of the fact that
dormammu uses spells that belong to
sidorak does not mean that dormammu is
less powerful than sidorak
it seems to be the case but it's not
necessarily an absolute case because it
could be
that sidorak no spells that dormammu
does not now all that would indicate
that it is based on
knowledge but dormammu himself is what
we call a fall team right he's literally
being composed of pure magic so i don't
know how you become more powerful
than a person who is composed of pure
magic you think they'd be able to do
pretty much anything
it's one of these things where in the
magical realm there really are not any
hard and fast rules here it's just kind
of like
you know it's it's one of these
interesting things and so again after
continuing to taunt
steven strange a little bit nightmare
ultimately reveals his hand right where
stephen strange steps in and says okay
look
like will you wake up man like we've
played out this scenario
time and time again and it always ends
in your defeat every time you make some
kind of a move and you try to put the
world to sleep which
you've never really successfully did on
this level before but anytime you ever
have a campaign like this it always
ends up with you being defeated why
would this be any different and the
responsive nightmare is where he really
kind of lets things loose and he says
vancouver seeing your world was not the
conclusion instead it was the beginning
that the idea of nightmare is on a much
grander scale now right
nightmare has no intention of just
conquering earth right
he has no intention of just conquering
the main marvel universe instead
nightmare is setting his sights on the
multiverse on conquering
every ounce of reality that is out there
and seemingly
using doctor strange to do it now here's
the way that that would most likely work
steven strange is a universal character
right i mean he is he is the sorcerer
supreme of the main marvel universe and
every universe
in the multiverse has its own sorcerer
supreme right the ultimate universe has
this version of doctor strange earth 98
which is where hero's age in real time
has its own version of doctor strange
its own
sorcerer supreme it may not necessarily
be steven strange it might be somebody
else
but every universe has its own sorcerer
supreme but the reality
is that even in being a sorcerer supreme
you're not necessarily
locked into your own universe right so
it's not like stephen strange is the
magical version of an infinity gauntlet
where all of his power and all of his
abilities are confined to his one
universe he could leave the universe
and go to an alternate reality not just
a different dimension but go to an
alternate reality
and still be able to manipulate his
magic right that tether continues on
into wherever it is that he's going
because he's invoking the magic of
others
it's not as though he opens that door to
an alternate reality and when he shuts
it he's cut off to all the different
magic that he has out there it doesn't
really work that way
but it's entirely possible that using
steven strange as a conduit and because
of the fact that he can reach out and
affect
different universes that he's kind of a
doorway here now the question that has
to be asked here is
how can nightmare possibly move through
stephen strange into other universes if
there are other sorcerer supremes out
there that could stop him well the first
answer to this is the fact that he's
captured steven strange
and pretty much all the characters who
exist in the main marvel universe
are usually the most powerful versions
of those characters occasionally you
could get different counterparts but
even if you look at like the marquee of
death and clyde winchem
clyde winchum originally debuted in an
alternate reality story but he became
the marquee of death in the main marvel
universe he's more powerful in the main
marvel universe right so that's usually
kind of how it works in marvel comics so
if nightmare can overpower
dr steven strange in the main marvel
universe presumably he can overpower and
take over anybody else
but the problem with this is that steven
strange mind is racing trying to
understand how
in the world this he could he could
possibly take out nightmare because he
even kind of goes on and he says like it
truly is
a bad dream come to life nightmare has
long been a dangerous foe but now his
power
is beyond recognition so in effect the
night the the power
of nightmare has been amplified several
times over
and not even steven strange can fully
understand how powerful he is
but the idea of nightmare engaging in
this action
putting the world to sleep bolstering
his abilities and then setting his
sights on conquering the universe
basically conquering all life throughout
the universe and then moving into the
multiverse does not go unnoticed
the first people to show up here are ego
the living planet galactus and the
celestials here's the downside to this
as soon as they pop up we never find out
how this how this battle takes place
right it's just the next thing you do is
you cut to the fact that he's standing
over them that nightmare has basically
conquered ego the living planet he's
conquered galactus and he's conquered
the celestials now the truth about this
is on the surface it might seem a little
disappointing that we don't necessarily
get to see this great big huge long
drawn-out fight
but the truth is that i think nightmare
being being able to dispatch them and
not really being shown
makes it a lot more significant right
because we've seen that happen before
we've seen that play out
time and time again now i know i know
it's not much can not much consolation
here right
because you know i personally would have
loved to have seen an
alex ross depiction of like a great big
huge cosmic battle
facing off against nightmare and all
that kind of stuff if i'm being honest
with you guys i think the only reason
why we're even seeing a story like this
in marvel comics is because of wanda
vision the nightmare is the one that's
basically behind everything but this is
the important thing it really even kind
of blows the mind of steven strange that
nightmare
is of such a such a power level that
he's able to overpower galactus and the
celestials and all those guys
and so at that point we basically end up
having him kind of taunting stephen
strange yet again right taunting him and
saying like any chance that you believe
that you had here
any chance that you believe that that
you could somehow survive this
or you could somehow stop me and
overpower me it's non-existent here
right understand that there's nothing
you can do
and so what this does is it leads to the
next stage of
you know cosmic entities getting
involved we get into the heavy hitters
lord chaos master order eternity uh the
living tribunal and even mistress death
right these guys step
in all with the intention of taking on
nightmare and what happens
nightmare overpowers every single one of
them just overpowers these guys now
this is where we're able to make the
credible statement that nightmare
becomes the one above all because the
one above all is the one who created the
living tribunal and granted there are
other dimensional beings out there that
are capable of destroying the living
tribunal for example you look into
something like
like the beyonders or something along
those lines and while nightmare is in
and of himself
not necessarily a being that is that is
part of the
traditional order of cosmic entities he
is by all standards of measurement right
he's a cosmic abstract right he is
a concept given a physical form if
dreams that we have as human beings the
collective
subconscious of us when we dream if they
could get up and walk around
it would be nightmare right that's
basically the form that it would take
and so this is
essentially an instance where a cosmic
abstract has found a way to violate the
natural order of things
bolster their power and then in turn
kill the living tribunal now does this
mean that we're gonna see
uh nightmare take on the one above all
it's entirely possible right i'm not
really sure yet because this is
basically the final issue
or the second to the final issue but
it's one of these things where stephen
strange kind of sees us right he says
like
at first i thought nightmare simply
wanted to conquer the waking realm now i
realize he wants to drain the energy of
every realm be it earthly or
metaphysical if beings as powerful as
these are helpless before him then truly
my plan has to succeed i only hope that
nightmare remains preoccupied by his
lust for power
and by his fascination with the dreams
of the living right
stephen strange just kind of looked at
that and says okay like we got one shot
right and if i'm not able to pull off
this one shot
then we're all going to be screwed and
so the way this basically ends is you
have nightmare kind of looking at this
and saying you know strange
i could do this forever and perhaps i
will perhaps i will crush your world
into dusk
and you will watch it happen secure in
the knowledge that you made it possible
for me
to destroy everything that you fought to
protect the truth about this and i'm
gonna be straight up with you guys
alex ross and kurt busek they're not the
kind of guys who would do something like
jim starlin where he just like invents
the cosmic
regulator and suddenly thanos just
becomes this omnipotent ridiculously op
being
they're not the kind of guys to do that
kurt musick one he's been writing comics
since
since forever right since like the 70s
and two like alex ross has written
and drawn quite a bit of comics and he's
got standards
and i doubt he would want to be part of
a story worse is kind of some hand-wavy
ending and so because of that
the plan of stephen strange is going to
be something tangible it's going to be
something significant
maybe it'll be the one above all i'm not
entirely sure but whatever it is it's
got to be something because what we're
basically dealing with right here is the
lord of nightmares who somehow managed
to get the upper hand
on every single cosmic entity up to and
including the living tribunal the only
thing above that is the one above all
that's where the buck
stops so unless stephen strange has
something insane up his sleeve
this is it this is where it all ends but
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explained make sure
you guys hit the sub button to become
part of the rob core if you guys enjoyed
this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you